[Music]  same device  saying hello  you think your wife can hear you no  wipe on  Maybe I'm Wrong  to die  maybe not goodbye to you my trusted  friend  [Music]  a new day is Dawning  new ideas no wounds  New Management  [Music]  who is this  challenging to single combat with a  loose it's a way out  I don't sit at the table your family  does please pray for me  I was a black sheep  [Music]  man has to look his best when it's time  to get married  or buried  I'm going to need a gun  by my friend  [Music]  if you win  the table will honor its word  you'll have your freedom  under the old laws only one can survive  to meet at sunrise  for results and execution  Last Words Winston just have fun aren't  they  [Music]  I want you to find your peace but the  good death  only comes after good life  [Music]  you and I left a good life behind a long  time ago my friend  [Music]